what can you do to put yourself in
pressure situations because the more you
get into pressure situations the better
you can be in handling them that's when
I was running SEAL training it was like
we're gonna put you in insane pressure
situations Mayhem situations and you're
going to start to learn how to do these
things and of course practicing
which is because a lack of confidence
can trigger you to choke because you
lack confidence and you choke how do you
get more confident you get good you
practice the more you practice the more
your confidence increases even doing
mental rehearsals of what you're gonna
do
is going to help out